from M night Shyamalan oh boy this
should be good comes one of the best
laugh-out-loud comings of 2008 that was
supposed to be a horror movie plan on
murdering me in my sleep
what no wow that didn't happen the
happening you love The Sixth Sense and
unbreakable you liked parts of sighs the
village and lady in the water made you
say oh but before the violent car crash
that was the last airbender there was
the happening of film about a thing that
happens there appears to be an event
happening
they've been affected by whatever's
happening cuz this really be happening
why is this happening is something
happening in a few states whatever is
happening is happening to small and
smaller populations then stops happening
nothing happened it's even dumber than
it sounds Mark Wahlberg delivers a
Donnie Wahlberg level performance as
Elliott more a science teacher with one
facial expression who's so inquisitive
he phrases everything like a question
toxin toxins effect he together along
with his dead wife and this silent
Deadeye girl they'll run from the least
scary monster in film history
gently rustling leaves
Wow they actually found trees more
boring than the ends experience the
first movie since Groundhog Day to make
suicide look kinda hilarious as trees
begin to emit a toxin that makes us kill
ourselves in the most convoluted ways
possible in this non mystery non
thriller that spoils itself in the first
act
it's the plants leaving you with plenty
of time for awkward dialogue why are you
giving me one useless piece of
information at a time the second ok just
give me a second awkward pauses we are
gonna die here whatever this is and not
much else
hey what's your take on hot dogs random
person you know hot dogs get a bad rap
got a cool shape dick got protein you
like hot dogs don't you good to know so
prepare for a viewing experience that
feels like The Walking Dead - zombies
plus a win machine full of complete non
sequiturs perfectly normal and during
shifts in tone that's all we're all
gonna be fine I got her to take my
daughter's handle this Unni is chasing I
knew that I knew that
as you wait for the inevitable Shyamalan
twist ending that never comes the twist
is there is no twist the trees did it
then it ends infant must've ended before
without their uh starring grass ferns
bushes leaves plastic trees Oaks Elms
I'm not sure what kind of tree that is
think it's a maple oh thank you maples
and a mannequin
are you okay what the [ __ ] is happening
should be more interests in science Jake
you know why
because your face is perfect okay
seriously what's up with this movie hey
guys what would you keep that scene in
the movie
weii my lemon drink who calls it a lemon
drink it's lemonade
I suppose the kind thing for me to do is
to offer you something what the hell is
happening right now you meet a strange
lady who's talking crazy to you and you
don't say a word to her then you just
join her for dinner
what no be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers every town has an elm
street I'm your boyfriend now Nancy
what's your favorite scary movie the
first monster you have to scare the
audience with is yourself one two
Freddy's coming for you thanks for the
nightmares